i have a voicemail here from someone
who is not pleased with my position on
outdoor masks
now i think it's really important for me
to state again
uh my position is that i think i am
going to listen to the cdc on masks
my position has been that all along and
this person
like many in the audience are sort of
upset with me about me saying
i think the cdc is right about pulling
back on outdoor masking in most
situations let's take a listen to this
and go piece by piece
hey david you say you're not for wearing
masks outdoors
again i've been wearing a mask outdoors
this entire time i didn't think it was
necessary
but i've been doing it because i just
follow the cdc guidelines
the cdc guidelines have now changed it's
not that i am for or against
i am listening to the cdc my question
for you
is would you be okay with someone
smoking at the same table as you
outdoors or smoking
right next to the door of your office
building so i guess two things there
smoking at the same table i don't really
know any smokers so there's no reason so
somebody should be smoking at my table
if you mean the next table over
there's a bunch of differences here
covet particles are
water droplets or aerosolized liquid
if you want to go in that direction
cigarette smoke is smoke
so the physics of it is totally
different coveted particles
aren't carcinogenic they don't have a
cumulative effect
over your lifetime secondhand smoke is
something that it has a
cumulative effect on the body over
lifetime there is some amount of covet
particles that could make you sick
and if it's below that threshold then
that's it
accumulating cigarette smoke over a
lifetime is bad so the analogy is the
same one tucker carlson made but it's
it's not a good one
or smoking right next to the open window
of your apartment
i'm guessing you would complain about
that and i'm asking what evidence
you have that carcinogens in
cigarettes aren't able to move as far
or are able to move further than covid
virus
yeah listen i i these are two completely
different things
smoke is smoke covered particles are are
liquid
so it's just none of it is making sense
to me we also know that it's not like
uh it did covet and cigarettes are also
dissimilar
in that essentially no one's getting
sick outside before anybody was
vaccinated the estimate is one out of a
thousand cases were transmitted outdoors
and we have to believe that those few
outdoor cases where people doing
obviously stupid things a big crowd on a
hiking trail or at a concert or whatever
the case may be
there's just no analogy we know it's not
an issue people
have not been getting sick in that way
particles
and i'm also wondering if you're not
for wearing masks outdoors
uh if someone goes from outdoors to
indoors they put their mask in their
pocket
what's preventing the particles on one
side of the mask from infecting the
other side of the mask well it's in the
pocket
and the particles collected on the mask
from getting onto the hands of people
oh god how do you expect people to
manage this i don't think most people
can
it's it's what's been done i mean the
entire time you know you go in somewhere
you put your mask on then at some point
the mask goes in your pocket
this is basically surface transmission
surface transmission has been shown to
be
almost zero remember at the beginning
all the stuff about bleach your
vegetables and
uh all of this different stuff it's been
determined it's not necessary
mask in the pocket then on the face the
particles move around
that's not how people are getting sick
so i'm not worried about that there's no
evidence that i need to worry about that
that if it's just in and out of your
pocket you've just moved everything the
mask is collected into your pocket
anyway yeah right but again we now know
that that type of surface-to-surface
stuff
is not how people are getting sick so my
question to these folks is
if you agreed with the cdc all along why
do you suddenly now not
believe what the cdc is saying i i've
just been listening to the cdc from the
start
um i think that that voicemail is
completely antithetical
to any known science we will have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about how americans are seeing
biden compared to barack obama
we will talk about the return of new
york police department's robot dog
and we will talk about a controversial
hand gesture
on jeopardy which may not be what it
seems all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com i'll see you then